avec alexandra aurions côte généticienne
ancienne directrice de recherche à
l'inserm
alexandra orio compte bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors pour commencer on l'a vu un des
nouveaux cas de contamination a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'elle différence au fond
entre les caps positif au qu'ovide et
les malades ducobu qu'est ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est bien de commencer par
cette question parce qu'en fait toutes
les mesures que vous venez de décrire
sont essentiellement fondée sur ce
paramètre et ce paramètre
il vous l'avez probablement compris il
est il indique sur la positivité à une
paix sierre le moka est dévoyée parce
que ça ne correspond pas enfin dans
l'imaginaire des scientifiques et des
médecins
normalement un cas c'est un malade on
sait qu' il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre le fait que vous soyez testés
positifs et que vous créiez des
symptômes du cofide donc on voit là
qu'on est en train de prendre toutes ses
décisions sur un un problème de
positivité de 2 pc à ce qui évidemment
est dérangeant 62% des personnes
positives au prix de 19 n'aurait pas de
symptômes
donc des porteurs sains donc mais
contagieux c'est avec cette réalité clos
port du masque prend tout son sens vous
devriez vous citez vous même le fait que
la lorsqu'on est positif on va avoir
entre voilà cinquante pour 60% certains
disent 90% de chances de ne pas être
porteur de moindre symptôme
donc on est en train de parler de
carcans finalement là
jory t60 vous avez dix 62% certains
10,90 qu'importe n'allons pas dans les
chiffres la majorité est véritablement
105-100 qu'ovide il ya plusieurs raisons
à cela c'est qu'en fait on demande à ce
test de nous renseigner sur ce qui ne
peut pas faire c'est à dire la
contagiosité
ce test qui peut juste dit est ce qu'il
ya des présences delà du disque dur on
va dire de dudu du virus alors ça ben
évidemment par exemple si jamais je
touche qu'elle un malade et que je mets
le doigt dans le nez avec l'onf et la
pca sur mes doigts on va retrouver que
mes doigts sont positifs vous comprenez
c'est donc vision véritablement une
circulation mais qui ne correspond pas
donc une circulation des séquences du
virus mais qui correspond pas au virus
mais est ce qu'on a ce qu'on a des
moyens de mesurer la contagiosité
aujourd'hui on aurait des moyens de le
faire on ne le fait pas c'est un point
crucial
par exemple il suffirait déjà pour avoir
ne serait-ce qu'une idée c'est de mettre
en place un observatoire sur les
transmissions secondaires d'un alors on
va dire je suis cas positifs et puis il
faudrait regarder si les mécas contacts
vont eux mêmes être positif et avoir un
observatoire pour suivre très
précisément si c'était juste des
positifs ou si c'était des positif avec
symptômes
or à aucun moment on dit mais il
faudrait que décrivez nouveau symptôme
est ce que vous avez de là tout est ce
que vous avez d écoulement nasal est ce
que tous aient tous ces points qui vont
engendrer une contagiosité évidemment
alors en termes de létalité la grippe et
le co vides sont finalement des
pourcentages
proches et vous nous le disiez 1 sur
cette antenne mi-septembre l'académie de
pharmacie réclame le vaccin contre la
grippe avec comme priorité les personnes
fragiles et les personnels soignants
c'est la première des choses à faire
aujourd'hui la première des choses à
faire je voulais dit effectivement sur
cette antenne ya quelque temps je vous
le redis avec encore plus d'acuité parce
qu'une étude vient de sortir montrant
que dans 39 pays
si on regarde le nombre de morts 2 co
vide dans ces pays ainsi que la
vaccination des plus de 65 ans moi qui
lie à une association positive c'est à
dire quoi ça veut dire que les les
endroits où il ya eu le plus de
vaccination des plus de 65 ans et là où
il ya eu le plus de morts de qu'ovide 19
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut pas dire
ça veut dire il faut impérativement
discuter ce point que j'apporte depuis
quelques mois
basée sur des études dont je vous avais
parlé la dernière fois mais l'a appuyé
sur encore d'autres études avant toute
chose donc faisons un point pour une
fois la preuve la médecine vous savez le
son symbole c'est le miroir est en haut
de ce bâton et de ce serpent est le
miroir c'est en fait la prudence et la
prudence c'est prendre de bonnes
décisions
c'est tout ce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
faire jusqu'à présent
si on pouvait prendre là cette fois ci
la bonne décision non pas sur des
habitudes de ce qu'on attend est ce
qu'on est en droit d'attendre d'une
vaccination contre la grippe
je pense que pour une fois on fait les
choses dans l'ordre ça me semble
fondamental alors il nous reste quelques
secondes juste peut-être cette dernière
question au niveau de la recherche
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui de la
molécule prometteuse de l'institut
pasteur de lille
on n'en sait pas grand chose
la mesure de leur communication qui est
encore très restreinte et on comprend
pourquoi
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est le principe le principe de cette
découverte entre guillemets découverte
c'est cette société aptus constituer une
banque de 2000 médicaments et et passent
en boucle ces différentes médicaments
qu'ils appellent molécule mais qui sont
finalement qui ont déjà été avec une
autorisation de mise sur le marché c'est
pour cela que ça peut aller très vite et
donc passe notamment l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et d'autres molécules
d'autres médicaments et on aurait trouvé
une un ancien médicament de parmi ces
2000 qui serait prometteur je n'en sais
pas plus actuellement je sais simplement
que j'espère qu'ils ont comparées par
rapport à l'asie trop me sinhala c'est
macrolides qui ont quand même donné
tellement de d'effets bénéfiques et
d'après les remontées qu'on peut en
avoir et on n'a pas beaucoup de
remontées de généralistes qui ont mis
leur patience aux antibiotiques et zinc
et avec une volonté très positive merci
beaucoup alexandra aurions code pour
votre analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
généticienne et ancienne directrice de
recherche à l'inserm